What was made?
Hi, let me switch to the music, there, now we can have the dress to impress music.
I tried to put on something fancy, I tried to dress to impress, do you like it, do I look cool?
Would you give me five stars? Shades, yep. We got shades today, so we're playing
Roblox, which is honestly a game I never thought I would play on stream.
But we're doing it, it's a game called dress to impress, it's basically where I don't have
a hangover, I'm just, I just, I'm just, I just ate some brownies before this, I don't want you to see
my eyes. It's a game where you, after a night of punishment, oh my god, this is dark. Okay, it's a
game where you basically, they give you a theme and you have to dress up your Roblox character
as that theme and then everyone takes their turn like going on the catwalk and we all vote for,
you know, we all give each other like ratings for our outfits and how well they stick to the
theme and stuff and, you know, there's winners and there's losers. I've already played a few games,
I can tell you that the kids, the children in Roblox are not on my side, they hate me.
There was one where I was, it was, I played one game where I was supposed to be like a meme,
like the, the theme was meme, right, and I dressed up as Pepe the Frog. I thought I did pretty good
compared to everyone else, but no, I literally got last place behind like a literal like,
naked person, like they were, they, they didn't adjust to their, their character at all, like
they didn't style it at all, I was so fucking pissed, like, I was losing my shit, this game actually
makes me mad, this game genuinely makes me really, really fucking mad. I don't think I'll rage as much
because I got, I got three other girls that, you know, can, can be on my side, give me, give me
more high ratings, please, I hope they do. Yeah, kids don't, these days don't know Peek when they
see it, exactly. Maybe they're just too, you know, they're just too, they're just too young,
they don't even know who Pepe the Frog is. They were probably thinking, what the fuck is this green
bitch? Yeah, they don't know. There's a reason why VTubers really stream Roblox outside of closed
lobby collabs. Wait, what's the reason? Am I hearing the game twice? What's going on here?
I don't know. Wait, what's the reason?
What is this song? It better not be copyrighted.
Anyways, I'm really happy to have been invited to this collab. I'm kind of shy. I'm a shy person in
collabs where I don't know people, so I might not like, I might not talk too much. I hope you
forgive me if I'm not too talkative. I'm shy. I am shy. So yeah, but I'll try to type and chat
to a little bit, see if I can. I'm guessing because everyone would join? Well, we're already in a lobby
together. You know? Already in a lobby together.
Eli is the only one I know, but she's a sweetheart, so don't be scared. I'm sure all the girls are
sweethearts. I'm just, I'm just, um, oh my god, I'm already so sweaty. I'm just shy.
I'm very shy, but I'm happy to have been invited. I'm just shy. Early in me, I know, I'm like
1am. It's basically 1am for me. I should be asleep at this time.
Oh, thank you. Thank you for the super chat. It's my sleep time, but have a good stream. Thank you.
Hmm. This music's kind of loud.
I might turn it down.
Enemy stream is early. Now I can actually watch you. Yeah. I don't know. I just, um,
you know, I just, I just streamed at whatever time they asked me. I'm pretty free when it comes to
the streaming times. I just usually don't stream early because I'm tired and asleep. I'm asleep
and tired, so that's why I usually don't stream this early.
I feel like this song is copyrighted.
Is this song copyrighted?
It is. This is just makes me a fuck. What the fuck, man?
They're just playing. Damn it. I really wanted to play the music from this game.
Damn.
Okay. Well, I'll be listening to Charlie XCX. You'll be listening to our regular background music.
Sorry.
Rats is summer? Hell yeah. Do I look cute? I think I look really cute. Listen, I was gonna,
I was gonna put on something else, but I got lazy and so I just looked through the
default VTube studio items and I saw these.
So yeah.
Also next week on Monday and Tuesday, I'm planning on going to a beach nearby and I'm so excited for
it. I'm so excited to go. I know I've been going on trips a lot, but it's only two days,
like you'll see me on Wednesday, you know? So it's fine. I'm not gonna be gone forever,
but I'm really excited. I'm so excited to go. I haven't been on a trip by myself in forever.
That's why I want to go because like peace and quiet. Peace and quiet, man. My family's really
loud and tiring, you know? So it'll be nice to have some peace and quiet. Also, I saw it,
I was looking through the Roblox characters and
listen, I folded. I feel like, okay, I feel like you can't see the emotion in my face.
I'm gonna take this item off. I feel like you can't see the emotion in my face. I want you to see me.
I saw the adorable Roblox
like characters that you can buy and I folded and I spent seven dollars and bought a Roblox.
Like, I bought a Roblox outfit. I spent seven dollars and I bought a Roblox outfit.
Vakini tryout pick? What? No, no, no, no. I only have one Vakini.
Vakini's, I don't, I'm not comfortable wearing Vakini's, so
I, uh,
I only have one Vakini and I'm not gonna show you a picture, absolutely not.
Seven dollars, I know.
I'll hold seven dollars. It's a lot. It's a lot. For me, it's a lot for a game.
For me, it's a lot for a game. Okay, I, I'm a, I'm a free to play player in every single game.
Can we at least get tan lines? Oh, no, I don't like to tan. Do you mean on this character?
No. I don't, I don't, I don't know. I, I'm not, like, I don't tan ever in real life.
Um, so, yeah.
A lot for a single outfit. It is, it is a lot. Yeah, that's like 75% of a McDonald's
combo. Now you're making me crave McDonald's. I made a new rule for myself, though, if I want to get
fast food, I'm not allowed to, sorry, I'm cleaning my glasses. Hold on. I made a new rule for myself.
If I want to get fast food, I'm not allowed to order it on Uber Eats. I have to go there myself and get it.
So, um, I, I, okay, I failed one time. I did order sushi one time, but it's sushi. It's healthy.
And it, I definitely didn't eat fried chicken with that sushi. Um, but I've been, I've been keeping to that
mostly now. So, I'm gonna have to get on the bus to go all the way to McDonald's.
Good way to start healthier. Yeah.
Okay, I'm ready to play. Uh, let's see if the other girls are ready.
Yeah, it's been about 10 minutes. Ready?
Oh, I have my French keyboard on and I always use the AX on.
Oh, is that AX on Grav or Aki? I don't know. Ready. Okay, Rui is ready.
I know it's so easy to hit that button. I know.
Um, Elia's ready. It's Elia, right? It's not Elia. It's Elia, right? Please tell me it's Elia.
Please tell me it's Elia. Please tell me her name is Elia. Please.
Jess is saying Elia's name weird on purpose. It's Elia?
Elia. Oops. Sorry. Elia. Elia.
She's not watching. It's okay. She's not here watching, right?
Elia. Okay. Elia Stilaria, right?
Right. Sorry. Um, okay. Everyone's ready. Oh, they already unmuted. Hold on.
The hair color. Oh, so all my face color changes.
It's like skin tones over here.
The palm tree. Skin tones. Look, only my face changes. Look at this.
It's only 36 seconds. Yeah, I'm not getting this one. I'm not ready.
Oh, shit. How do I get out of here? How do I get out of it once I'm done?
Oh, my gosh. You're so fast.
I'm skipping this round.
Oh, you're so fast. Okay. It's too fast. I only have 15 seconds.
I'm competing. I'm winning. I'm playing to win.
Right. Yeah, you guys, I told you I'm competitive.
Gotta beat these kiddos. Gotta show them who's boss.
Oh, my God. Oh, shit. Oh, my God. I win. Please vote for me.
Thank you. Thank you.
It's cute. It's cute. That's cute. Yeah. I like it.
Wow. And she's so sporty. Look at that.
Do the clips on the runway.
This is so stressful. I didn't expect it.
Oh, wow, girly. How did she get those lids?
It's the makeup and the Botox.
By Dr. K. Dr. K?
From Beverly Hills. I'm making up my name.
Oh, this one's more like summer. Yeah.
Oh, don't forget to pose. Oh, I had you guys muted the entire time.
Oh, it's okay. It's the voices in my head.
You're like, why are you talking to yourself, Laffy?
It's kind of not spring, I think.
It's giving her red carpet than spring. Yeah.
Who's this beauty?
She's slaying. Five stars.
Five stars. Three for spring.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I'll gladly be your spring fluff from Queen.
How'd you get that color so bright?
Five stars, five stars, five stars.
I wasn't ready. Five stars, five stars.
Look at that square head.
That girl, you know, it's very natural.
I was going for the natural look.
That's so pretty.
Our parents are going to spin.
Look, the green. She's a tree.
How do I stop spinning? Okay.
Good dizzy.
Could you also not change your hair color?
You can. You can change your hair color.
I tried. I clicked it, but it just stayed black.
This is the summer again.
That's cute.
It is cute. I don't like that cup, though.
So many people are using that cup.
Yeah. Oh, that cup.
Boba.
An original.
The winners. Come on. Come on. Come on.
Me. Let's go.
Oh, my God. We're already in it.
Oh, my God. We're the children.
We're ugly.
Why are you lost?
Someone put ugly.
What?
Ugly. Why can't I give a theme?
I was suggesting a theme.
Wait. Oh, how do I move?
I'm trying to name my...
I'm going to make a custom theme.
I'm going to put VTuber.
Hey, how come?
I put Ilya.
They're going to be so confused.
They're going to be like, what the heck is a VTuber?
Wait, I have a theme prop.
She's someone who will buy it.
Okay, I didn't buy a theme.
I'm putting hololive.
I'm putting...
Heck yeah.
They asked Pat for some suggestions
and they gave me some for theme.
Good job, chat.
Wait, I have to have theme props?
What's that?
Theme props?
You need...
I guess you have to get it.
I tried getting one because I had extra leftover robots.
Wait, someone said little chocolate cracker.
Cry mom.
Oh, my God.
The theme is hololive.
Let's go.
Is that how you translate it?
Because it's German for me.
Chat is translated, yeah.
It's translated?
Hololive.
It keeps my outfit.
It's hololive.
Oh, my gosh.
Who's the easiest...
I'll try the holo guys over.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, guys.
Put holo guys over.
I don't remember the holo guys.
Okay, okay, okay.
I choose holo.
I choose either.
I choose...
Wait, we're choosing?
Yeah, we don't want to know where we want it.
I think not just a surprise.
Like, we didn't see...
Oh, I choose you guys.
Maybe I should change then so we don't know.
Actually, yeah, yeah, I'm changing.
Can we look up references?
I don't remember.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's fine.
You can totally look up references.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, do we add new hairstyle?
Let's see if I can get the hairstyle.
I want to look up the reference too, you know.
All right.
Okay.
Okay, I'm looking in.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh, God, this is hard.
Oh, God, the time limit is pressure.
It's like embedded time pressure.
Why are the skin colors so strange?
Oh, what the heck?
Why did I get kicked out?
Oh, no.
Ah!
Can you time me out?
Wait, let me...
Thanks, thanks.
Like, why am I purple?
What the hell?
How do I have a normal skin color?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
The bangs aren't going away with that.
Need shoes, need shoes.
This is close enough.
Okay, and then...
I'm getting married.
God, these are ugly bangs.
Be gone.
No, the hair color isn't changing.
Oh, this is so hard.
Did it?
This is pretty hard.
Oh, no.
Stressful.
How do I get rid of?
Wait, how do I put the clothes off?
I'm still wearing the dress from Lustrone.
There's a button on the right.
On the right.
Yeah.
Ah!
And then you press the X.
Did you get it?
Uh, um, um, no, no, no.
No?
No.
Oh, my hair is gone.
That's something.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, good, good, good.
And then, oh, God, this is hard.
No one asked what's the theme.
What's all alive?
We need...
And then we need strings.
And then we need shorts.
You can stack hair that's so helpful.
I know, right?
Yeah, the hair stack is a...
Difficult.
Oh, God, I need shoes.
Oh, man, this is so...
It's gonna be really hard to guess the characters I feel like.
Someone's able to...
Who are the dresses?
Buy for 700?
Do I look rich?
Can I have some of these?
I need a...
Oh, God, how many things can I layer on?
Where are the dresses?
Where are the clothes?
Is there...
Is there any sweater with a hoodie?
I think so.
Oh, my God, this is difficult.
I need a...
Something to go on my head.
Belt through the belt.
I really took my shirt off, fuck.
Oh, socks.
Oh, no.
Actually...
I need like a crown.
Oh, my God.
Put on.
Where's the belt?
Oh, it's so over.
I'm sorry.
You have me too.
I'm so lost.
Where's the belt?
Oh, God.
Where is the accessories?
Why?
Oh, my God.
There's only two minutes left.
There's one minute left.
I can kind of see the vision on mine, though.
Like a bit.
I can't see why.
That's good.
I can't see the vision on mine at all.
Say thank you, guys.
Maybe.
I want to see the vision.
Oh, oh, yeah.
I tell you.
How do I get out of the hair thing when I'm done with it?
Of space.
But see me so much time.
I've been just sat there till the time's out.
Wait, there's only two rooms for clothes, right?
Or am I missing something?
Yeah, the other room is like...
VIP.
Yeah.
There's no thighs.
Oh, hey.
Thighs.
Let's go.
Oh, I need it.
Oh, where's the necklaces?
Is there a choker somewhere?
Oh, yeah.
Good enough.
Are there socks anywhere?
There's thighs.
There's thigh highs?
There's thigh.
Yeah, here, here.
Where?
If you face the hairdressing room and go out, then on the left.
Oh, okay.
Where the glasses are and the hats.
No ribbons?
No ribbons.
On the left.
Need ears.
Where do I get ears?
Here.
Where?
What?
I don't have time.
No.
Oh, no, there's only 10 seconds left.
I already have 10 seconds.
I have to get out of time.
Where's the ears?
Oh, there's the thigh highs.
Oh, my God.
Where's the beady with the hat on?
Oh, no, I don't have time.
Bye.
Oh, no.
Good luck.
Let's see up.
That's who...
Who is this?
Who's this coconut drinking punk?
One star.
Who is this?
They don't know.
I think you can also chat to say who is...
Yeah, who is this?
Ah, I'm writing chat.
Who is this?
Yeah, I want to know.
If I'm able to recognize it, I'd like to know.
They censored me.
What the heck?
Who is this?
I just went and knocked my VTuber.
I didn't understand the theme.
These kids don't know what VTubers are.
They need to learn.
They need to learn, yeah.
We got to school.
Okay, wait.
Ayo?
No, why would we censor?
Yeah, how can we censor?
And what are you saying?
VTubers.
VTubers censor.
Oh, look at me.
Wait, why is VTubers...
Wait, wait, wait.
I can't change the hair color.
Mine is censored too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, Laffy, no.
Laffy, no.
Wait, Laffy, wait, wait.
Why can't you do that?
Oh, wait, Laffy, that's so bad.
I'm so sorry, Laffy.
Is this Gora?
Yes.
Did you go Gora?
Yeah, Gora.
Oh, my God, you're the...
Cawaii.
Gora, that's cute.
Thank you, thank you.
How come VTubers are censored?
Wait, what if I only type VTuber?
Oh, is it censored?
It is, it is.
Is this Cali?
It's Cali.
Oh, that looks good.
That's so good.
It does look super good.
Very accurate.
Immediately recognized.
It is.
I found a crown and I was like, I can do it.
Oh, my God.
No.
That's some bells.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
That's the only thing I'm going to find
that kind of close in.
No, it looks really good.
Oh, my God.
I thought I can't change the hair color, though.
Look, I click the colors, but they just stay black.
There's something you need to pay attention to.
Did you press on the check mark?
Who is this?
I know.
I'm not sure.
Sora in fancy clothing.
The hair color fits.
What if I knew VTubers?
Oh, it's so censored.
Yeah, it's censored.
It's VEE.
Weird.
Who's this?
They said that it didn't get it.
I didn't get it.
What the heck?
No one knows.
That's a lot of people that didn't get it.
You guys are noobs.
Not cultured.
Not cultured enough.
You're not cultured.
You guys are noobs.
This is a chat.
YouTubers.
Not your censor, too.
Hello.
Oh, God.
That's nice.
Yeah, they didn't understand the assignment.
New tab.
How do I do a new tab?
Sittings?
New tab.
Be the sitting.
I'm going to think of fantabit.
We failed our mission.
VTubers censorship.
Yeah.
What the hell?
No way to go.
Let's go.
I know the red has got it.
You guys are always owning it.
We're cooking.
We'll be cooking.
Let's see.
Can we do...
Like you've seen the mission, right?
There's like blue and then there's a red and white.
Who is it though?
It's Sora.
Oh.
Okay.
I get a cross.
I see the vision.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Never doubt, Jimmy.
We're putting in a costume.
Wait, you can change the music here?
Is this what this is?
Oh, really?
No, it's just the brat shop.
Oh, there's an apple.
What is apple dance?
What is that?
They don't even show you what it is?
They just want me to buy it.
Would you like to buy?
No.
Got to get money from those kids somehow.
Oh, it's League of Legends.
Yeah, great choice.
The kids aren't going to understand that.
They're like, you're like more common, isn't it?
Like they're going to be in shambles.
Okay, let's go.
Oh god, I hope we can do this.
Okay.
Who's League of Legends character I sound like?
I forgot the name.
Hold on.
Who is the League character?
Teemo, Teemo, Teemo.
Okay, Teemo.
I'm going to be Teemo.
Can you do the Teemo laugh?
I don't know what the Teemo laugh is.
Okay, I'll keep this.
Kinda.
I don't play League.
I just know I kind of sound like Teemo a little bit.
I don't play either.
I mean, I tried it, but.
Yeah, I tried it.
Yeah, I'm kind of trash.
Oh, great game.
Great game.
Quality game.
Pink.
How do I make it pink?
Oh, which character should I kind of be?
Oh, this is going to be hard, Ordo.
Like this kind of pink.
And then eyes maybe pink.
Everything's so expensive.
Did you guys know there's a Walmart land in Roblox?
A what?
What?
A Walmart land.
There is.
Yeah.
What do you usually do in Roblox?
I don't know anything.
I know so many things you can do.
It's mostly a lot of like mini games, I think.
Right?
Yeah, I love mini games.
Yeah, mini games.
I have no idea.
Wait, I can wear a man pants?
Hello?
Yeah, I know it's that.
Yeah, I know, right?
You can't wear guy clothes.
That's so weird.
Does that...
Do you have to like be a guy to wear the guy clothes?
I guess.
How does that work?
Guys, I've no idea what league champion to dress as.
I'm so lost.
But you play league the most.
I know, so I'm so lost.
I'm like...
There's so many options.
I know, right?
Okay.
Let's uh...
I need gloves.
I want to change color right now.
Oh, there you go.
All right, let me change the color.
Maybe, this is the closest I could think of.
There's no spiky hair anywhere.
I think I saw a nickel just now.
That might be me.
I can't...
There's no hairs that are close enough to it.
I think.
Is there skin tied shirt somewhere?
Oh, this is good.
Oh no, it's $3,500.
No, thank you.
Oh, I can't do anything.
This is the most I can do.
Oh, actually, I don't like it.
I wish I could take my bra off.
Teemo doesn't wear oil.
I don't know how to make the spiky hair.
But you want to make Teemo?
Yeah!
I want to make Teemo.
That's what I'm trying to do right now.
Oh, fuck, wrong pants.
Oops.
If there's only two minutes left.
Oh my gosh, I spent too much time.
Why is it on top?
Why is this on top?
Why is the layering weird?
Is there like a mermaid?
I swear I saw someone with like a fishtail.
I saw someone with like a fishtail.
Where did they get that from?
They probably paid for it.
What?
Oh, what the fuck?
Is there a scarf anywhere?
I need a top.
Oh, here's a scarf.
I'm so lost.
I look terrible.
I look nothing like Teemo.
I look nothing like what I'm supposed to be.
I need longer pants, I think.
Like this.
There we go.
What do I do?
Is there a flower somewhere?
Where did I find that crown before?
Oh my god.
You barefoot?
I'm so lost.
Okay, wait, where's the makeup?
Oh, there, okay.
Yeah.
Oh, I can do that.
What the fuck is this?
I'm terrifying.
I'm going to gasify Teemo.
Oh god, there's like one minute and I don't hate Teemo.
There you go.
I'm just going to do this pink.
I want a fishtail.
I got bamboozled by someone else with a fishtail.
I thought I could be Nami, but no.
No, I think I see the vision again,
but I said that last time, so maybe not.
Oh god, there's one minute left.
Wait, oh, what do I do for shoes?
Brown, maybe?
Wait, do you guys play League?
How many of you play League?
I play League.
I tried it, at least.
Laffy?
There's no tail.
Laffy is gone.
There is no tail.
There's nothing.
It's hard to guess.
Where's the flower?
There's already a flower.
I'm looking for a shirt.
Makeup, make it skin color.
Actually, I think I saw Nicola somewhere.
There we go.
This one.
This theme is difficult.
I always have no shoes.
Why are my tits popping out of my shirt?
What's going on?
What the hell?
Do I have a bra or something?
I don't.
Oh god, it's over.
It's over?
I didn't change my skin color.
Oh god.
Oh, who is this?
I just tried.
Oh, damn.
That is difficult.
I have no idea what characters are.
I'm sorry.
I'm a toxic Roblox player.
Who is this?
Yeah.
Wait, Laffy, you mute.
Is she the thing guy?
She was muted.
You were muted.
Oh no.
It is Lux.
Yeah.
This theme is best.
He's cute though.
I tried.
You put.
We're not good.
It's not good at all.
Very good.
It's very good.
Thank you.
Oh, I forgot to pose.
Shit.
Oh my goodness.
Imagine this is a mermaid.
That's so pretty though.
It does though.
It does look like a mermaid.
Pose, pose, pose, pose.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Yay.
I wish I could whistle.
Yeah.
There's no fishtail and I didn't change the color.
I can't do anything.
Yeah, Nico.
I can't find the hair.
No spiky hair.
It looks spiky.
Wow.
You know so much about the game, do you?
This is, um,
Nope.
I don't recognize this character.
Yeah.
Nope.
Toxic.
Well, the P makes it cute.
They're going to look up League of Legends.
Now look what's going to happen.
They're going to be like, what is it?
Google's League of Legends.
We've started the addiction.
We did.
Which character?
They're going to be curious.
Which character is this?
I don't know.
What is this?
V.
What is V?
V?
V like V?
Downvote.
Oh, what?
What is going on?
Wait, how did she do that?
Wait, there's the Nami.
That's so cool.
How did she do that?
It's a fishtail dress.
Even I don't know how to play.
Four stars.
Okay.
How did it count?
I can't keep it down too far.
How the heck did they do that?
Yeah, what the hell?
I don't know.
This looks like a Winks Club character.
Yeah, right?
It does.
All VIP?
Wait, I have...
Where are the VIP?
Maybe they bought it?
I don't know.
I didn't see it.
That's so crazy.
Near Rising Star?
What?
Dude, that third one was so Nami-like.
It was fourth place.
Yeah, it was so good.
It was really good.
Where the heck did they get that from?
Here, I'll do something every...
I'm pretty sure all of these kids know this.
If they don't...
What did you put in?
Fortnite.
Fortnite?
No, I don't know Fortnite.
I did my little pony.
Oh, my little pony.
Oh, that's perfect.
How does one dress like my little pony?
Or like a human version of my little pony?
It's a little pony character.
So not a pony?
Yeah, yeah.
Like the...
My little human.
They have humanized version in the show.
It's called...
Oh.
Hold on.
Can you get up now?
Yeah.
Equestria girls.
You can dress as the equestria girls.
And they're already humans.
Ooh.
Okay.
Searching.
We're doing my research for this.
Oh, that's kind of uncanny.
It is a little uncanny.
That's cute.
It is cute.
Let's go.
That's cute.
Wait, it's starting?
Oh, shit.
My little pony.
Okay, let's go.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
If I can change my hair color.
I just want to change my skin color.
Get naked.
I'm going to try to be fluttershy.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'll do...
I don't know which one's which.
I just picked one that kind of looked...
Is there no color close enough though?
I think...
Oh, actually...
Maybe...
This one's so cute though.
And then I'll do...
This is...
Do you guys have a favorite My Little Pony character?
I never watched this.
I don't know anyone.
The only one I know my name is Fluttershy.
That's okay.
How do I do this?
We should do wings next.
We should.
That would be cute.
Where'd the pants go?
Is this a pony tail?
Oh.
You can't...
I think...
Damn it.
I know, someone's excited.
I've been waiting for this moment for my life.
But are you a bit really?
My little...
You like My Little Pony?
No, some person put it in.
Someone in chat said it.
The brownies are coming.
Let's make the thing pinkish.
Okay.
What's all this money on the floor for?
What can I do with it?
I think you can buy stuff from it.
Like in the game?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
I'm about to make the cutest Fluttershy ever.
Yeah, what should I...
Oh, Ribbon's cute.
Where's the hair accessories?
I still have a man face.
700!
Oh my god.
That's expensive for that dress.
You can't afford that VIP.
Got to start getting a job in Roblox.
This hair is too bright.
That's kind of cute.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, I need shoes.
I need shoes.
What about this?
Wait.
Oh no, I'm getting the same glitch
where my clothing isn't changing color.
Are some...
Is some clothing locked in the color?
I don't think so.
Oh never mind.
You just have to up the dark value.
Because it's on the black.
On the black.
Yeah, it's on the black end.
That was my problem.
Okay.
Here we go.
And then where's the socks?
I think this one's kind of cute too.
Oh no.
There's the socks.
I keep forgetting that you can actually wear the other...
Oh, oh come on.
Why do they let you...
Why do they let you layer clothing
if they don't actually let you layer clothing?
Right?
It's like lifting sometimes, right?
Yeah.
What is this?
The order is random too, right?
It's like I'll put on a belt.
No, I won't.
You're not allowed to see the belt.
You can have it, but you're not allowed to see it.
Oh, the patterns are so ugly.
What?
Hair clips.
Where are you?
So sorry.
I need to change my shirt again.
Are there hair clips somewhere?
I don't know.
I was hoping there would be.
I need to use hair clips.
There we go.
This doesn't look good.
I don't know.
It's okay.
We'll vote five stars for each other and we'll totally...
Oh my god!
I just saw the prettiest...
Fuck, I forgot the name of my whole body character.
Holy shit.
Twilight, Twilight, Twilight.
I just saw the prettiest Twilight character
walk by me.
Holy shit.
I don't know.
Is there a lollipop somewhere?
I'm not sure.
That'd be kind of cute.
34 seconds.
This would be cute.
Oh, I know that one.
That's Twilight.
That's something I was expecting.
Okay, cute accessories.
Oh.
Ice cream maybe?
So I'm the closest I can have with just ice cream.
Coco not to die, so no.
I did ice cream instead.
I don't know if there's a lollipop somewhere.
Oh, are you doing Pinkie Pie?
Is that why you have candy?
Oh.
Oh, no, I'm talking minty.
Are you doing minty?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Minty's my favorite character.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Okay, this is Rarity, right?
This is cute.
A little bit.
I feel like for Rarity, it's a little bit toned down.
Mmm.
Yeah.
Rarity would do way more than that.
Oh, you did Fluttershy too?
Yeah.
The only one I knew.
That's so cute.
That's cute.
I guess the human version is reference, like you said.
Adorable.
Fluttershy's been meeling.
Oh, another Fluttershy.
Oh, my god.
A stylish one this time.
I love it.
I feel like a bunch of these.
Three of us went for Fluttershy.
I went for Fluttershy.
Oh, no.
Fluttershy.
For your magic.
Oh, my god.
I'm surprised no one did Rainbow Dash.
Rainbow Dash is hard to make with the rainbow hair.
Rainbow hair.
If she's like.
Yeah, exactly.
I think you can do, like, duos or partners, right?
I think you can.
Yeah.
Minty.
Oh, so cute.
I was trying to look for a lollipop, because like the circle one,
because it looks like the one in her butt or leg.
Yeah, her cutie line.
Yeah.
Oh, that's so cute.
That's so cute.
That's Twilight, right?
Yeah.
You might recognize it.
It looks really good.
I don't know why the ice cream's there, but the rest looks so good.
Flay, Queen.
Oh, Rainbow Stick and Voyage 2.
That's true.
Uh, who is this?
Oh, Pinkie Pie?
Look, it's cute too.
Oh my gosh, I'm making one.
I can't.
I'm so scared of the kids.
Yeah, I'm trying to be in Legend of Jenny.
Okay, this is Rarity, right?
That's pretty.
Is it Rarity?
Who is this?
Wow.
Oh, Rarity, yeah.
Wendy's kid's so good.
Right?
Holy shit.
Matter popping off when we did My Little Pony.
What's some other popular kid's stuff that we know?
Oh, shit.
I don't know.
Yeah, you wanted to do, was it Winks?
Winks, yeah.
Yeah, Winks, yeah.
Do you think it stays no Winks?
I don't know.
I don't know Winks.
It's a hard generation.
Let's find out.
Okay, sure.
We'll find out.
Just vote one star and get it over with.
Oh, sorry.
I joined with two minutes.
Damn, girl.
Just vote once.
Are you going to win?
Okay, this is the only one I'll vote one star.
Okay, say I'm doing this.
Why do they say they vote one star?
That's so mean.
They got no mercy.
Yeah.
A Power Rangers.
That's also a good idea.
That's so good.
Wow, you're awesome.
Oh, damn.
They slayed.
You guys slayed too.
But I really like the Verdi.
Thank you.
Should we do Winks then?
Yes, Winks is a good one.
Who's your favorite Winks girl?
I think I like the orange.
I forgot their name.
Okay, I need to look them up.
I need to look them up too.
The orange-haired one is my favorite.
Oh, the orange-haired one is really cute.
Main character.
I think I like the black-haired one.
Musa?
I think I'll do the purple.
She's my favorite too.
I'll try Musa.
Let me see.
Winks Club.
I used to cosplay as Bloom in the elementary school.
Oh, really?
I used to wink at all.
Yeah.
I'll try doing Stella.
Oh, she's cute.
I don't even know what the text suit looking thing is.
I forgot her name.
Oh, I know which one you're talking about.
She has Winks.
She has pink hair.
Techna, I think.
Techna.
Yeah, Techna.
Starting.
Oh my gosh, you need to be faster.
Here we go.
Oh, it's starting.
Oh, no.
I haven't picked one.
Let's see here.
All right, I'm going to do...
Oh, no.
You know what?
I don't know who to be.
Close enough, I guess.
I actually never watched Winks Club ever.
Oh, really?
Really?
I played the PS2 game mainly.
I don't think I watched it either.
I read mostly the comic because we had the comics before.
I'll try and be Flora.
I don't know.
I found the perfect hairstyle.
Let's go.
Kind of.
Okay.
No.
Wait, she's weird.
Oh, no.
Okay, hair.
I found the perfect shirt.
Oh my god.
And then I need...
Whiteish.
Don't forget the wings.
They all have wings.
Yeah.
Can't forget those.
Hmm.
Why is it clipping?
Anyone that doesn't clip?
Oh, that one kind of.
Oh.
I want to run.
There.
I know.
It's so annoying when you're like running out of time
and you're trying to go to the next area,
but you can't fucking run.
I need a beanie somewhere.
I need like arm bands.
Oh, there they are.
Oh, I hate that it's clipping.
I wish it doesn't clip.
Oh, no.
I know.
How am I supposed to unleash my full creativity?
Do you guys like know stuff about layering
Eldred's Aerial 2 or like color theory and stuff?
No.
Oh my god, color theory.
I want to do the color theory.
You sound so professional.
I'm going to do the color theory thing so badly
when you like...
Okay.
...someone to figure out all your colors.
Oh, I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Or it's so cool.
It would be cool, but I don't know if I believe those.
I don't know.
I can definitely like...
My wings are gone.
What the heck?
The clipping hurts.
Where do I see the fairy?
Is there a fairy wing specifically?
Yes, there is.
Oh, there is.
Okay.
Purple.
Juice.
Is there a headband anywhere?
I don't see any.
I hate the wings.
Why did you find the fairy wings?
Where are they?
They're...
What are they supposed to be?
If you face away from the hair stuff,
they're on the right.
They're on the right?
Sound them.
Right?
Where?
When you face away from the hair dressing stuff, then...
On the right.
Away in the right.
Um, like...
If you...
Wait, where?
If you look at the Lana salon,
and then go left from there,
and keep going straight for a long time,
and then they're on the right.
Yeah, there you are.
Holy crap, you walk so fast.
Yeah, because I have to walk fast, thing.
Oh, damn it.
I see someone else that shows Stella,
and they look so much better than me.
Ah, fuck.
No!
It's like...
I'm getting plain-ish, but...
I don't know.
Maybe there's a pattern,
glittery pattern, or something.
Plus bracelets.
Oh.
Kind of like yellow purse.
What's that?
Oh my god.
I'm just trying to, like,
copy a reference image.
I'm so lost.
Same.
Just like...
How do people get so creative
with their designs
while also looking like the character?
You're like, I'm just trying to...
I'm just trying to copy the reference image.
Yeah.
I am.
I'm just looking like the reference.
I'm just trying to copy the reference image.
It's like, they're so fashionable,
but at the same time,
it's exactly looks like the same.
Yeah, like the same character.
Yeah.
Where do people get like...
This is all I can do.
Where do people get like,
pretty headwear?
And under here.
Oh, this.
Oh my god.
No armbands though.
It looks okay.
What is this?
Oh, I have no idea.
This one.
I need a shiny, shiny heckin...
Oh, I want to give up.
I'm being humbled so hard.
We're being humbled by the kids.
Mine is just so simple,
because it's the coolest one.
Everything's glipping too, unfortunately.
I just want to give up.
I give up.
I want to give up.
It's the same.
Wait, my skin is still yellow.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, shoot.
No, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
Okay.
I don't look like a cheeto.
Come on.
Why is nothing like what I'm supposed to?
Oh my god.
Okay, that's actually a cheeto.
What the hell?
Oh, man.
That's a bloom.
Two, three stars.
That was pain.
Three stars?
That looks so good.
Three stars.
Black hair.
Sapphire like me.
Let's go.
Mewsa.
I can opt out by not wearing anything.
I'm going naked, guys.
You gotta pose.
There you go.
Let's go.
That looks so cute.
The spit out.
Thank you.
Five stars.
Yeah, five stars.
Thank you.
Looks like the smile, the snack that smiles back.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
I panicked.
I don't know.
That looks good.
Yeah.
I don't even know which one I picked.
I just picked the first one.
No, it looks like her.
You did good.
That's adorable.
Body complete.
Oh.
Eggna.
Oh, that's so good.
Wait.
That's so good.
Looks so much like her.
Yeah, I tried the closest possible,
but the clothes are clipping though, the white stuff.
It looks like sparkles kind of.
It's okay.
She's just sparkling.
No, someone else did.
It's nowhere near as good as mine.
Two stars.
I went with one.
My Stella comes first.
Oh, that's pretty.
That's so pretty.
And they have different wings too.
Damn it.
See what there's wings from?
These punks.
These punks are spending money on the game.
These kids.
Paying for a free to play game.
Where are they?
Pathetic.
Oh, you can fly?
Whoa.
What?
How do you do that?
I don't know.
It looks.
Oh, there's so many poses like pose one, two, three, four,
five and stuff.
Maybe one of those.
Probably.
Pick random buttons for the best.
Ooh.
Good.
It's cute.
This one's really cute too.
Yeah, very red though, I think.
Why do people do that?
I don't know.
That's a character.
Ready to pose.
Oh, my gosh.
The winners are got mugged.
Let's go.
Yay.
Oh, my gosh.
With dominating the ranks.
I'm stuck.
Why am I stuck in this pose?
I know, right?
It sticks to my pose.
Because I've been taking the theme.
Everyone's like, what the hell is this?
Got mugged by previous?
Oh, god.
Yeah, the theme will be random now.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
I'm skipping so others have a triumph.
I am.
The poor kid's probably like, could she all stop?
They're like, what are these boomers themes?
Boomers.
The team took over.
Wait.
She needs to spread leg one.
Oh, boomer theme would be funny.
Wait, I'm also stuck in the pose.
How do I?
I haven't got enough.
Which one's the spread leg pose?
Oh, it's like one of the numbered ones.
Spread one, two, one, six, seven, eight.
I've got enough to custom name it.
Just sliding.
Oh, you're 12-1.
Yeah.
Oh, my god.
This looks so fucking wee.
Spread eagle.
Mythology.
It's true.
I don't know anything about mythology.
Mythos, guys.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, I'm going to try going for Poseidon.
I'm going to try Athena.
We had to wait and do my pose and walking like this forever.
Wait, I don't know how to do it.
We had to wait and do my pose.
Oh, well, I'm just going to have to walk like this.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, okay.
Oh, man.
That's actually really hard.
Oh, actually, no, no, no, no.
I can't undo.
I'm walking like this forever.
You just choose a different one,
and then you can like click on it and then unclick.
Oh, okay, thank you.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, god.
I'm going to do...
We're still dressed.
I'm dressed.
No.
Oh, no.
When I don't have a reference to coffee from,
I get so uncreated.
I know you too.
That's why you always get a reference.
I did not have a tight dress.
This is the only thing I can do.
It kicked me out of my shirt.
Buy it.
Oh, lame.
Lame.
Lame's house.
Oh, expensive.
So lame.
This one?
Hmm.
Oh, never mind.
That's ugly.
I'll leave it behind.
What's this?
Where's the skirt?
Are there skirts?
Maybe this one?
I don't have money.
Why is it so expensive?
$4,000?
$5,000 for the dress?
Right?
This one was like $3,000.
I'm like, why?
Why is it so expensive?
Oh, my God.
Inflation even hit roblox.
Darn inflation.
Where is the skirt?
This one's sparkly.
All right.
And then what should I do for top?
I think.
What about this one?
Oh, this one's free.
Okay.
Never mind.
It's not free.
They trick you and then they show you the picture of like,
would you like to purchase?
Right?
I feel so lame.
How do you make this like unique?
Oh, not like this.
Not like this.
Well, you can choose patterns.
Oh, you can just.
Yeah.
What?
I have no clue.
Damn.
Okay.
Whoa.
There's a lot too.
Oh, this is so much more helpful.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
How do I?
Never mind.
Actually, how do I get this off of me there?
I'm going to choose a pattern.
Okay.
See shows.
Or like this one.
And then the top can be seashells.
Fuck yeah.
Okay.
Now I look a little bit.
Yeah, I think we're cooking.
We're cooking.
Kind of.
We're trying to cook.
We're attempting to cook.
It's like.
Yeah, we're attempting.
We're attempting.
Yeah.
Trying to make some kind of like microwave meal.
Out of the freezer.
Straight up.
Okay.
I think I'm done.
I need a head fan for the head.
Mine looks nothing like mythology.
I'm starting to realize.
Mine looks like a beach girl.
Fuck.
Where's the flowers?
Shit.
All right.
Cooking on a budget.
Yeah.
Cooking some ramen or something.
That's what we're cooking.
Oh, that looks better.
Okay.
There you go.
That's cute.
Okay.
Poseidon's probably rich and has lots of jewelry.
Like they don't.
Usually they all have tons of jewelry on, right?
Yeah.
Like yeah.
Slap and jewelry on.
Oh, what the frick?
Oh, there's some.
Mermaid swimming outside.
What's underneath?
There is.
Oh, that mermaid's going to win.
How did they get out of there?
Hey, where'd you get the mermaid?
What the?
Oh my god.
VIP, I guess.
Yeah.
For sure.
Oh, there's gloves down here.
I didn't.
There's socks.
Whoa.
What the hell?
Do you see the green mermaid?
Yeah.
It's wild.
Oh, shit.
There's only three seconds left.
I don't have shoes.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, I just.
I tried.
I'm going to ask her from Okami.
She's a wolf goddess.
So I have like ears on my hood and stuff.
I like it.
I like it too.
It works.
Oh, there's a code.
Use code mermaid for tail.
Where do I put the code?
Is that the code?
Is that the affiliate code for Roblox?
Wait.
Imagine.
There's a saddle thing.
Wow.
That's so cute.
Is it cute?
I even.
Yes.
I tried.
Cute.
High five.
That's so cute.
She must have fish mouth.
The fish mouth.
Oh, there's a code when voting ends.
The code we shall do.
Okay.
Oh, I need a bigger giant boots to become Aphrodite.
Who is it?
So pretty.
That's so pretty.
It lacked in the boob department, but that's fine.
Wait.
Who is it?
Aphrodite.
Oh, wow.
Five stars.
Oh, you guys went all out.
What the heck?
That looks really good.
Athena.
Yeah.
That's really good.
Oh, I forgot to pose.
Oh, mermaids.
She went in for mermaids.
Why is she bald?
This is the purest form of mermaids.
They are mermaids, I guess.
Exactly.
I mean, it does.
It's siren.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that is so good.
That is so pretty.
It's crazy.
I'll have to vote four stars for that.
That's good.
We got a blend in, guys.
We got a blend in.
What is this?
Oh.
Oh, that's true.
No.
Once.
I don't really know how.
Lay.
And serve with a logical name here.
Oh, God.
Not me.
Oh, that looks like a fancy lady.
Yeah, that's like a fancy lady.
Slender woman.
That's not mythology.
What?
It's not.
Oh, God.
Michael Jackson.
Yeah, I was saying the same thing.
Does Kyla look like that?
That is, um, what's she?
The Yeti.
The Abominable Snowman.
Are Yeti's mythology?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
The mythology is not God's.
I think Yeti would be like what you call the monsters.
Let me find my look.
I don't know.
That's cool.
You won against the freaking mermaid.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
So where's the code?
It says after voting.
Yeah, there's the code.
Google dressed him.
Where?
Where's the code?
Wait, where?
On the bottom left?
No.
Mm.
It says code.
Oh, yeah.
I found it.
It says invalid.
How was the spelling again?
I was looking at the code.
M.
It was M3R.
Invalid code.
It's an ID.
Something like that.
It's invalid code.
I got invalid code, too.
This is not working.
It's invalid.
Wait, is it like only, it only works once?
Oh, me?
Oh.
Hey, I so-
What can I get in the room?
I'm a streamer.
Oh, me.
They're in stream chat.
Who's stream chat?
Someone's in stream chat?
Oh, of mine.
Oh, you can get cute shit.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, you guys want me to copy pasta?
It's a lot, though.
Yes?
Yeah.
Okay, it's a lot.
Let's see.
Or I'll just-
I'll screenshot and then I'll send to you guys.
Oh, I got a cute-
It's like a cute bear.
It's like a lot of outfits.
Wait, how do these codes work?
How do people just get codes?
I know, right?
Yeah.
I'm just kidding.
Wait, what's the theme?
Prince or princess?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm already waiting.
I'm just kidding.
Thank you for all the codes.
Thank you.
Wow, yeah, so cute.
Oh, you can do them all.
It's time to be a princess.
See, princess.
Well, we can't use guys' clothes, right?
So-
If you want to change to a guy, then you can't-
How do I change to a guy?
How do I-
Well, it's like in the back at the men area.
Oh, you want to change your-
Yes, I'm going to be a-
Wow!
You're a man?
Yeah.
I'm going to be the only man.
Is there a crown?
A man?
A stinky bug.
A man's tree?
Is that a boy's smell?
Oh, my gosh.
That boy's smell.
Is that a boy's smell?
But it's a prince.
It's a prince, you smell.
That's what you're smelling.
I am not just a boy.
I am a prince.
Prince.
Not like the other boys.
There's not really a lot of men options.
Is there?
Hmm.
What's the prettiest dress I don't have to go into depth for?
Can I wear the girl clothes?
I don't think so.
I can wear them.
6,000!
You can't wait.
So men can wear women's clothes.
Only some stuff.
Not all of them.
Damn.
Okay.
It's like expensive.
All the dresses are expensive.
Like-
This is going to be rough.
It's rough out here for the boys.
What the hell?
Oh, man.
What's the most royal color?
They know, right?
Can I wear like any of these shoes?
What the fuck?
Put on.
I have to wear ugly fucking sneakers.
Maybe it was a bad idea to choose to be a dude.
It's like three minutes to be a girl again.
No, I'm sticking to my choice.
I'm sticking to it.
The prettiest princess can marry the prince.
I'm just going to be watery.
Watery?
Or like a-
Oh, a lot.
A lottery.
I also understood watery.
Watery.
Watery?
Colors, no.
I spent the most time with the hair trying to change the color.
I think it's makeup for me.
Can't decide.
Okay, dress, dress, dress, dress.
Are there any free dresses that are not-
I- I- I- I- I believe 700, I guess.
Oh god, I've got this thing blocking my view.
I actually can't see.
It's like five robots.
I'm like, I don't wanna!
Okay.
Please tell me I can wear girl hair.
Oh, this is so ugly.
All my layers back on.
Today I learned I am not a princess.
I am not a prince either.
I tried.
Oh god, it's getting worse.
Oh my god, these faces are so funny.
Why don't any of them have noses?
There's only like three that have noses.
No nose.
Nobody knows.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
Why don't you put on the dress?
Oh no.
No time, no time, no time, no time.
There's no hacking time.
Oh, that's not a princess dress.
Never mind a board.
Okay, wait, hold on.
I have to go to the bathroom really bad.
I'll be right back.
Tell me if I win.
All right.
All right, go ahead.
You look gorgeous, by the way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, like the most the most the sexiest prince ever.
That's so funny.
Oh, I just got a friend request.
What?
You out here making friends on Ruthless.
Let's go.
I'm getting all the babes by dressing up like this.
Oh, this one's pretty.
Oh man, I haven't been voting for any of them.
I've not been.
The good ones.
This isn't princess sign.
How about princess?
That's not very princess like.
What's that?
It's not princess like or etiquette.
No princess etiquette.
I don't know how to write etiquette.
Wait, that crown attack.
Oh god, no princess etiquette.
Oh, geez.
That crown is.
Wow, look at them.
It's kind of mermaidy, but then how did they do the crown?
Codes.
It's Bambicodes now.
Let's check the code.
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Are I code good?
Was there another dude?
Okay, code.
Yeah, I was.
Oh my god.
He stole my spotlight.
That's okay.
You got the friend request.
Not him.
Oh my god.
So, merm.
Oh yeah, you get it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that's so pretty.
Oh my gosh, guys.
Okay, what else we got?
Fashion.
Lana.
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute.
Let's see what.
Love boots.
Hideo.
Invalid.
What do you mean?
Oh, I mean.
Bella.
Where do we see this then?
If we.
Wait, so it's not just once per use?
You can get it.
Oh, where do we?
Where do we find it somewhere?
Oh my god.
Look at the cat.
Actually, bunny.
Oh, bunny.
That's so cute.
Good.
This one work.
Bella.
I'll vote for the next theme.
Cowboy.
No, game night.
Let's go.
Oh, White 2K is nice, too.
Game night.
I went for cowboy.
A lot of people use cowboys or white 2K.
What's white 2K?
What's that?
3,000, like old school, like mean girls.
Yeah.
Oh.
Some of the kids own.
I went up the kids now.
Lots of ribbons, I think, ish.
Or something.
We're talking.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh, that would be cute.
Wait, what was the theme?
I didn't see it either.
I thought it was white 2K, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, white 2K.
Awesome.
They looked that up.
White 2K.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that.
OK, OK, OK.
Got it.
Let's do this.
What kind of hair do they have, though?
Kind of like buns, braids.
White 2K.
Like, in this ish.
Yeah.
White 2K.
OK, fashion.
I'm going to look up some references.
Yeah, that's fine.
I'm looking at myself, too.
I have a reference.
All right.
I don't want to be a man anymore.
I change my mind.
I give up being a man.
I don't want to do it.
It's too hard.
They got no options.
Oh.
This one definitely.
I need a sweater.
This is cool.
So where do we find the ones we just unlocked, too?
I'm not sure.
I just check on the code area.
You can get them up.
They're coming only in the VIP room.
Oh, is it only in the VIP room?
I don't know.
No, you just click on the codes
and then I actually click on the item.
Oh, yeah.
You go to the code place.
It's actually a picture.
Oh, oh, I remember.
Hey, that's so cute.
I love it.
Whoa.
Okay.
I need some low-rise hiking trousers
and some gummy shoes.
Let's go.
I got tank tops and stuff, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Tank tops are pretty Y2K, I think.
I don't know.
Hmm.
Oh, that's hard.
And then I need...
They're too young to know Y2K?
I think they'll know.
I don't know.
It's very popular lately, I think.
Yeah, the fashion kind of came back.
Mm-hmm.
And stuff.
What about accessories?
Do they have, like, crazy accessories?
Yeah, yeah.
You can have Y2K flip phone.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah, the flip phone.
Hey, shoes.
What shoes?
Do they have any shoes?
I definitely look the mean girl part.
Yeah.
Oh, these shoes look better.
Damn it.
Oh, yeah, I'll change the shoe.
The butt is so pronounced on this game.
What's so pronounced?
The butt.
The butt?
The butt is so pronounced.
It's very sensitive.
You don't judge me, but she...
You get it wrong.
Laffy has to be Gat.
The Gat.
Sorry, Gat.
So skibbity toilet.
Wow.
Yeah, so she's like, Gat.
Very demurr, very cutesy.
Did you guys see the demurr thing?
It's everywhere since yesterday.
I don't get it.
You don't get it?
I mean, I saw like the theme or like everyone's like,
it's from the original like, oh, so demurr.
Yeah, you see how I do my makeup for work.
Yeah, this is so considerate.
So demurr.
Yeah, very cutesy.
Very cutesy.
I don't wear a green cut crease to work.
I'm noticing that I don't know anything about colors.
Like, I don't know how to match colors at all.
Yeah, me neither.
I don't...
I'm not a fashionable person in real life.
Maybe this bank.
Oh, this is cute.
Okay.
Um, I just copied a picture from Pinterest, to be honest.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
Um, where are some other...
What are other accessories?
Wait, would it be like this?
This hanging bangle?
I don't know.
How do I...
How are people outside?
What are they...
Yeah, there's someone dancing around outside.
I don't know.
There's someone dancing around outside.
Oh, yeah, I'm getting there.
Oh, there's one minute left.
I'm looking for Y2K jewelry.
Is this Y2K?
What is Y2K?
Yeah, I don't know about the jewelry, too.
I just bought a lot of jewelry because I think they're very...
Yes, I think they're very jewelry-y, right?
Are you ready?
Yeah, I think so, too.
That's why I put, like, two or three drawers.
Ohio Sigmund, baby Gronk.
Oh, what?
Is that Y2K to you?
Okay.
Kind of looks like Y2K, I think.
Oh, my God.
My chat gets auto-translated to German
and there's just some stuff that doesn't make any sense in there.
I have no idea what people are saying.
Michael, don't leave me here!
Michael!
That's what they're saying.
Oh, wait.
And the girl is trying to show the baddie nays?
What?
Wait, what is this?
It says no one wants baddie nails.
What?
Oh, what?
That's what they said.
The baddie nails.
I forgot to add nails to my character.
Wow, this is kind of nice.
Hello?
And those wigs!
Oh, yeah, you like those?
Those wigs.
That looks Y2K.
Yeah.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Oh, my God.
And Michael Jackson.
Wait.
Click on the positive sign next to a lot.
What's the positive sign?
The positive sign.
Oh, that's me!
Hey, yo!
That's yo!
Yo!
The baddie.
I love you.
Hey, let's go.
Oh, we've only been in the green team.
That's why it's so fancy.
Look, the background is calling us breasts.
You're called Karen-ish.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Excuse me!
You look good.
This is very like the case.
Oh, the shirt.
I love it.
That's really good.
I love the hair.
I really feel it.
It's so adorable.
You see?
Bop-bop, bop-bop.
Oh, let's go.
I love the teddy bear necklace.
Over the shirt.
Oh, my God.
That's annoying.
You guys did so good with the Y2K theme.
What the hell?
Oh, the necklace is so cute, too.
Oh, my God.
You said the necklace was so cute.
This is kind of like...
It's cute.
It is cute.
The nails are cute.
Elf's way 2K.
Oh, my God.
Wow, what's the move?
I like that.
I like that dance move.
Wait, it looks like color on it.
Wait, what did they say?
The second to last chat message?
What's that?
Which one?
Karin-ish.
It looks Karin-ish.
Someone called me Karin-ish.
Who was that?
Someone called Indifference.
Yeah, Indifference.
Since I don't think anyone here knows what Y2K is.
Yeah.
What?
They just called you guys old in like five languages.
Oh, God.
It's so funny.
If you want bad e-nails, follow me next round.
Okay, thank you.
How do you do that?
How do you do the bad e-nails?
There's a nailed studio.
Yeah, there's a nailed studio.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay, okay.
And you can get different nails.
Oh, that one's so cute, too.
Oh, this gives us such...
I could wear this.
Right?
Yeah, brats, exactly.
Yeah.
Like brats, it'd be perfect.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Oh, no.
Oh, music kind of slaps, too.
Oh, I forgot they're supposed to be turned it off.
They play like copyrighted music, by the way.
Oh, really?
Oh, my God.
Unless...
Yeah, so if you have it on stream, be careful.
Oh, really?
Yeah, it's copyrighted.
Um, um, um...
There.
I turned mine on so I could hear it well.
I'd be buying them.
I didn't text.
Let's go.
I can't wait to get them.
I'm so sick of it.
That's cute.
I love it.
They're all matchy.
Yay!
Noice.
Oh, my God.
All right, more codes.
I'm typing more stuff.
Yeah.
More codes.
I forgot.
So many.
How do you guys get these codes?
Yeah, where did you find these?
I think it's on the other side.
If the other is not lineable.
Some of them are invalid, I think.
Maybe it's, like, expired.
Maybe.
Let's see.
Codes.
Oh, that's cute.
I like that one.
It's cute.
They're love-less.
Let me...
It's...
Just...
Oh, pretty.
They're call-less.
She's funny.
Call-less.
I think I got everything.
Wow.
Oh, the creek hat is so cute.
Right?
I like it, too.
We definitely get that, too.
Oh, I think that was a few things.
Oops.
All right, all right.
Wow, so cute.
Fashion.
Oh, that's so cute.
Ashley Bunny.
Ashley.
And then...
Oh, my God.
I can't tell Ashley Bunny.
It was a theme.
Oh, that's so cute.
What's this one?
Oh, fancy.
Oh, you can see myself.
Oh, Vibes.
What the heck's 24?
What do people wear in 2014?
What's 2014, Vibes?
I'm googling it now.
What is it?
2014 has a volume.
Maybe like Emo?
Is that Emo?
When I said 2014, everything's like normal.
Or maybe like Disney.
I think maybe Disney stuff with lots of layering.
That's what I think, baby.
Not according to Google.
It's like...
Yeah, it's so different.
I see faddles or Emo, too.
And I guess like ripped jeans.
Scarps.
Jeans.
Shorts.
Oh, underwear, I guess.
That's what you were saying.
Oh, I don't know.
I've over-asked.
I don't know.
It's tough.
I guess I'm just going to go with this.
I'm going to try to go with like some Hannah Montana look, maybe.
Hannah Montana was popular, right?
In 2014.
That was earlier.
I think it was over by then, right?
I'm sorry to tell you.
Are we done?
Oh, my God.
Our age is short.
We're Hag Maxing.
Maybe we should set the theme to Hag Maxing.
Because I don't think I know what's going on.
Oh, my God.
Are there like grandmas or something?
Grandmas!
We need that.
Let's do it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Maybe this one.
Actually, maybe this one is cute.
I'm going to try going for Hannah Montana.
I know it wasn't popular, but I feel like I'm going to try going for it.
How are you going to feel if those kids say it?
What is Hannah Montana?
I'm going to cry!
Oh, God.
You can cry.
That's what I'm going to do.
What do you mean?
What is Hannah Montana?
I'm going to put everything in.
You're going to put everything in your head.
I don't know.
2014.
Maybe I'm just going to use...
I was going to go with the first one.
This one looks good.
I'm going to go for like, I don't know, some kind of festival look.
I don't know.
Why just Google?
Google hip to the best.
Yeah, I am.
Maybe I can go to Google.
I was just wearing sweatpants and hoodies in 2014.
That's what I always wear on the time.
Oh, there's a microphone here.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
Gross socks.
Oh my God.
I need some socks.
And then...
Oh, you can climb up the shelf.
What the heck?
You can climb up the shelves.
Yeah.
I did that accidentally too.
Oh, you kind of can.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a headband over there.
I could have used that.
I don't want to use a thing.
I'll use it right.
Oh, you have to buy the headband.
Never mind.
You even have to buy the headband.
You even have to buy a headband.
Lame.
$3,000.
Layers.
More layers.
There's like cardigans and stuff.
Where are the cardigans?
Yeah, where are the cardigans?
I need one too.
Hair.
What kind of hair?
Dang it.
You need this one?
Oh, what the heck?
What the heck?
I shouldn't have chose Hannah Montana.
I shouldn't have gone with her.
I'm failing.
There's someone.
I'm just failing really badly.
It doesn't look anything like Hannah Montana.
I don't know what I'm like.
Where are the hoods?
Hoodies.
There was like another hoodie.
Hats.
Oh, there.
Okay, sorry.
What are my hats?
This.
Give me that.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
They look like I'm just going to school or like...
Except for spectators.
Oh, I don't know.
Going to school.
I mean, it's 2014.
I mean, 2014.
Oh my god, 2014.
2014.
You could go to school.
It's cool.
I think I'll die there in 2014, right?
Maybe, maybe not like this.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
There's accessories.
X.
And accessories.
How do I change the color of the hair?
What?
Oh, there we go.
And then I want it.
All right, I'm good, I think.
Oh my god.
This hair is killing me.
No, I hate it when they click me out.
Yeah, then I get up to chair.
I'm still working here.
Wow, to cook.
Yeah.
Perfection takes time.
Come on.
All right.
I have no idea.
Thanks.
I don't understand.
Okay.
Maybe we should have dressed Attack on Titan
because Attack on Titan got popular in 2014, right?
And like, popularized anime.
That's true.
Attack on Titan did get popular.
I am no later what I'm doing.
Say I'm glasses.
Now this is a theme game.
The sunglasses shoot.
No, no.
No.
I haven't got a button.
I don't have anything.
Give me that.
D.
No.
Oh, god.
I was just a basic boy.
Oh, my gosh.
Why am I always first?
I don't want to go first.
Oh, thank you.
I don't need it.
That's very cute, though.
I love this.
You like my shoes?
I like it.
This shoes are adorable.
Why I need to post on them.
Oh, it was happening in 2014.
What happened in 2014?
Chats are lost.
What's in 2014?
Oh, I need to write.
Oh, I know.
I need to write Hannah Montana.
Okay, there.
Pause.
Me too.
Wait, the girl.
What?
Chats are rude.
I knew it.
Girl, what?
Wait, I need to ask them.
Do you guys know Hannah Montana?
I think they better know Hannah Montana.
Okay.
It's also cute.
The little melon.
Adorable.
The hell is Hannah Montana?
Someone said yes.
Someone said yes, though.
Someone said the hell is Hannah Montana?
Are you kidding me?
I think they're not even sure.
Yes, I think.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Man, what the hell?
Wait, let's ask what they know Miley Cyrus.
Miley Cyrus.
They know Miley Cyrus.
They have to know Miley Cyrus.
Exactly.
Thank you, Helsinki.
Wait, she's censored.
Wait, why?
Hannah Montana is Miley before the wrecking ball.
Hannah Montana.
No.
Oh, my God.
The girl.
Oh, that's so cute.
Hannah is Miley.
Who is Miley?
Oh, God.
Endifference.
What do you watch?
This is not skivvidy.
This is not what we do.
I have to tell them.
Oh, my God.
Endifference didn't pass the live check.
Oh, this is very pretty.
That's not, not very sigma.
Oh, my God.
That's sigma.
He knows it.
Ellen Masco.
Oh, my God.
He knows it.
Why?
Why aren't you lying?
Oh, God.
I came in like a wrecking ball.
Yes, he's her father.
Oh, my God.
Wrong dad.
I also know the funny numbers.
Funny numbers?
What's funny numbers?
I also know the funny numbers, man.
Who?
69?
420?
24?
I don't know any other funny numbers.
Yeah.
These people were still in the womb in 2014.
Trill.
Yep.
He gave me a tiger truck and he smashed it.
Oh, my God.
I feel so old.
I didn't expect to come out of this.
I'm depressed.
Oh, my God.
What the heck's going on?
I don't know.
I don't know what to say, Milano.
They don't know head on Montana.
I don't know.
Miley's like, not even Miley's like.
Oh, damn.
Yeah.
Set the next theme to like,
heck, you know, Bach on.
Like.
Oh, yeah.
Let's do grandma themes.
I won.
What?
Let's go.
Let's come back.
Do I have enough?
I don't think I have themes anymore.
No.
Pop, pop, power rangers.
Not enough theme prop.
Dying it.
I want to do grandma.
I don't have enough anymore.
Oh, dang it.
I feel myself turning to death.
So old.
We can get through this.
Yep.
In death, we're all the same.
We will meet them again one day.
And then.
We all end up in the same spot at the end.
Exactly.
Oh, my God.
That's not a child.
You're telling me that's not a child.
He's like, oh, I insulted so many children.
That's he's telling me he's not a child.
Why is not a child?
Insulted one too many toddlers.
But I'm a VC band.
Wait, toddlers?
Someone said, does anyone have VC?
Wait, there's a VC?
Wait, why VC?
I want to join VC.
I don't want to join VC.
Absolutely not.
I want to join VC.
Just to get cursed open, little kids.
How do you even use VC?
How do we join?
I don't think there's even a VC here.
Is there?
I think I said you have to like connect your phone to like.
Your phone.
And parents let their children do that.
Oh, it's no day.
People let their children do that.
I mean, I don't think people are paying attention
to what their children are doing on Roblox.
Yeah.
So over.
Oh, people are just going to all look the same.
I know.
That's why I say on the site to think if there's something.
I got to do something.
We got to do something different.
I think this.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Maybe I'll do like a light pink.
Oh, white.
How about a nice winter skirt?
It is cute, actually.
Hmm.
I think for game chat, you have to verify your ID.
No.
Yeah.
No verification.
Maybe there's some verification, but I feel like your ID.
Oh, this is cute.
Oh, make it like.
Let's see.
Let's go.
Hmm.
I think all my person is going to freeze,
but I'm giving her some trousers.
This is this is not a very wintry look.
I missed up.
I already saw like five people look exactly like me.
Yeah.
I look exactly like all the other girls.
Oh, no.
You are like other girls.
I'm exactly like the other girls.
Middle school me would be so embarrassed.
I'm going to go.
Oh, maybe I can do a pattern.
Oh, I keep forgetting there's patterns.
Something something something snowy.
Or maybe this one.
Oh, that looks awful.
Oh, wait.
Wait, the patterns are so cute.
What?
Yeah, the patterns are adorable.
Let's see here.
No.
I'm here to look as basic as the rest of them.
Too many options now.
I don't read.
No.
I'm going to take this backpack off.
It's ugly.
Who would wear this in winter?
Um, the hot girls.
Hot girls don't get cold.
Okay.
They don't get cold.
So of course they would wear this in winter.
Of course they would.
What else would they wear?
Like the fashionable clothes?
No, no.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, no matter the weather.
Yeah.
The girls would get it.
Get it.
I'm going to try putting on nails for the first time.
Oh, hair, hair, hair, hair.
Wait, that's not hair.
And then I don't know how to make them longer though.
Oh, well.
Wait, I'm actually kind of slain.
What the heck?
Hmm.
I'm going to so freeze if I wore this in winter.
That's okay.
It's worth it.
I can't even see why they're all there.
What color did I choose?
Shit.
This is good.
Why is my hair pinkish?
What is going on?
Huh?
No, they kicked me out of the chair.
Whatever.
Okay, I need gloves.
I need shoes.
Shit.
Wear the gloves.
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah.
Gloves is a good idea.
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Where are they?
Boots, boots, boots.
That's not gloves.
That's not gloves either.
Uh, here we go.
Wear the gloves.
I can't find them either.
Oh, they're down here at the end.
Oh, they have.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, they have socks.
Oh, right now.
These gloves.
There we go.
Oh, a scarf.
A scarf makes so much sense.
Where are you going?
Yeah.
All right.
I'm ready.
Oh, there.
Oh, that's cute.
Where's the high socks?
That would look good, I think.
My legs are going to freeze.
All right, I'm good.
Oh, Teddy's like.
Yeah.
My legs are going to freeze, too.
It's okay.
It's worth it.
Everything else is warm.
Yeah.
Let's see if I can quickly change my makeup
to something prettier.
Five seconds.
Oh, god.
There's no time.
Damn it.
Confirm.
Oh, my gosh.
Wow.
That is so pretty.
Thank you.
Oh, my god.
How did you do that?
I've surprised myself.
Dry the layers.
The layer is so cute.
We slay, slay.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, the tummy is freezing.
The tummy is freezing.
Oh, my god.
I love the boots.
Actually, I want those.
Like in all black, too.
Oh, there's no queen.
It's Elsa.
It does look like Elsa.
Yeah, Elsa was the female.
It's going for her.
Oh, my gosh.
Going for Elsa.
And then I gave up on the rest of Elsa
after I did the hair.
Well, immediately.
Right.
You guys look perfect.
Oh, my god.
It's a Jimmy Bees.
And you.
Thank you.
You got the highest praise just now.
The bunny.
And there's no bunny.
No bunny.
So cute.
Hypothermia is a small price to pay.
To pay.
Exactly.
Why is it different so mean?
They keep getting censored.
Snowball fight.
Oh, that's cute.
A white apple.
Is that a white apple?
Oh, oh.
Oh, my.
They would freeze to death, though.
We all would.
Unlike the rest of us that are definitely
also going to freeze to death.
Oh, my god.
Or the bag.
Wow, bad ass.
I'm rating this lower just because
they weren't original with the fluffy stuff.
Oh, yeah.
And I'm not even posing.
Oh, god.
I died.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Oh, same thing.
This is pretty basic.
Same as the other one.
Yeah.
Basic.
Let me be what?
Oh, oh, yeah.
Fan.
I think.
Oh, my god.
Oh, this one's cute, too.
But I gotta rate it low.
You're using this.
Yeah, I'm using this.
It's all the white and the fluff.
Oh, gosh.
We got someone self-priming in there.
Wait, what?
Self-priming in the Roblox chat.
Wait, can there is?
Can we do this, too, wait?
I actually know there's kids here.
I can't.
I don't want the Roblox kids.
Yeah.
Fine.
It's fine.
I'm fine.
I'm sorry.
It looks bad.
I have 4K subs.
Yo, who this punk?
Damn, I didn't have a 4K subs.
I'm not saying anything.
Oh, my god.
Interesting.
I'm not saying anything.
Oh, god.
Let's go.
Oh, it's finished.
Self-priming.
Let's go.
Not rigged at all.
Like, in the slightest.
No, I'm not rigged at all.
I'm not rigged at all.
No, we wouldn't rig the.
Oh, my god.
That's the most subs in the lobby.
Yeah.
I'm not going to say a thing.
Don't tell.
Don't say anything.
Wait a minute.
Oh, don't say anything.
I don't want people from Roblox to come to street.
What are you here for?
Are they talking about the young insminors or something?
Well, subs, though.
Like, like 4K subs on Twitch or YouTube or TikTok.
I guess TikTok.
Ask them.
Say YouTube or Twitch.
Probably TikTok.
No, but like, go wait.
4K and Twitch would be impressive.
Very impressive.
Oh, god.
There's 14 year olds.
Oh, geez.
Wait, are they even allowed to have YouTube?
Yeah, I think it's 13 plus, right?
Yeah, it is 13 plus, probably.
I see you.
I was like 12, but let's.
We all were.
My favorite singer.
Okay.
Oh, got it.
This is how you begin.
Freak.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Mine is dead.
Your favorite singer is dead?
Oh, god.
Yeah, too.
Michael Jackson and the lead singer from Lincoln Park.
Oh, okay.
Let's see.
I don't know.
All right.
I'm going to do that.
I know what to do.
Yeah, I know what to do.
None of my favorites do the same thing.
Don't have any style.
Yeah, my favorite singers don't have any style either.
Like, um.
Where's the simple style, but.
Um.
Oh, shit.
I'm just going to dress up as Justin Bieber.
I'm going to be absolutely cool.
I'm hot.
I'm going to do hot.
I think it was so good.
That's a good idea.
Good.
Shit.
That's such a good idea.
Oh, okay.
Is that a twin tail?
Great.
No.
I'm going to oopsies.
There's no real twin tail.
Oh, no.
I'm going to become a believer.
Okay.
I'm going to go for.
Time to become a Hatsune Miku.
Hatsune Miku.
Oh, no.
I can't change that.
I'm going to speak British people.
What?
Who said that?
Oh, no.
I'm already failing in the hair stage.
Oh, gosh.
Um.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Great.
Hmm.
All right.
Let's see what Bieber dressed up as in like 20.
I don't know.
When was he popular?
20, 10, 20, 10.
20, 13.
Okay.
Wasn't he born in 2010 or something?
Oh, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I don't know.
Probably had baggy pants.
Oh, this looks good.
I'm going to be patterned.
This.
Oh.
Big lips.
Mine is so simple, I think.
She dresses so simple.
Glyps, I think.
Oh, it's going to be dark.
Make them believe.
Believe.
The hair kind of darker.
Can I, can I not wear a singular man, man shirt?
Can't be put on.
And on this wild.
All right.
Clipping off.
This song will be stuck in your head.
It's getting there.
You're going to start dreaming about it.
Justin Bieber wore a lot of purple, I think.
I think mine is not recognizable,
but this is the only thing she wears.
Maybe something longer.
Actually, what is?
Enter VC and start singing for them.
Let's see.
I don't know if this will work.
Is your hat today, Mika?
It looks so good.
Oh, my God.
There's two.
So good.
Oh, no.
It's a two.
I need shoes.
She lied.
Do, do, do, do, do, do.
I'm missing.
I'm just Yassified Bieber.
Yeah, the only thing she wears.
Always in black outfit.
I need to find that I can think that I'm looking for.
All right, I think I'm done my Bieber.
Yeah, I think I think I'm done too.
But I'm so simple.
I don't know.
Does Bieber play basketball?
Oh, I see a Michael Jackson.
Damn.
Oh.
He had the Michael Jackson.
Unless there's like, there's no button up.
There's no mic anywhere.
Oh, where do you get the mic?
Oh, it's down the end.
Yeah.
Where the, where the backs are and stuff and the wings.
Yeah, where the wings are.
Oh, yeah, there it is.
Maybe I'll wear this instead.
There.
Yeah, that looks more like Bieber.
Five seconds.
Oh, oh, God.
Yeah.
Two.
Oh, God.
One.
Oh, oh, God.
I want simple.
Okay.
Let me go.
I like the, I like the hair strip of pink.
Yeah.
That's cute.
I swear, if they don't know who Hatsune Miku is.
Oh, wait.
That's, that's, that's the thing.
You never mind.
That's my thoughts again.
Recognize this.
Oh, let's go indifference.
The redemption arc.
I can't say Justin Bieber in chat.
I can't just, I can't.
What about Bieber?
Wait, just right.
Babe, babe, babe.
I can't say Justin Bieber in chat.
Yeah, I'm just never ate it.
What the heck?
Oh, my God.
So cute.
There she is.
Oh, my God.
It's so cute.
Miku.
Another Miku.
Pose, Miku, pose.
Another one.
Oh, no.
I did, I know.
That's so good.
I love it.
If it's her.
Oh, it works so well.
She always wear like fancy black long dresses.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
Wait, that's female.
That's female.
My little Jackson.
It is.
Where's the moonwalk?
We need the moonwalk.
Oh, my God.
Who is this?
Some K-pop guys.
Looks like K-pop guys.
It could be any K-pop guy.
True, true, true.
Generic singer.
It's here.
This looks like it could be.
Nicki Minaj.
Right?
Nicki.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Not sure.
Let's see if I can spell her name.
Don't recognize.
Very green.
Anyways, I'm very popular singer censored.
Yeah.
I think you have to separate it.
Like first name and last name, which is weird.
Yo, who is this?
Who is this?
What?
Why does Roblox censor half the chat?
I'm going to say the whole chat's just like censored.
I can't read this.
Traverse.
Why is a celebrity censored?
Like are they, are kids not allowed to?
Like a celebrity?
Because they say.
Oh my god.
No, that's true.
May I have your attention, please?
Oh, it's Eminem.
That's a good one.
I like that one.
Can you stand up?
It's back to Fortnite.
I'm back to Fortnite.
Come on.
Jesus.
The Tiki.
Let's go.
Let's go, Miku.
Miku's.
I'm going to sub our microphone.
Please.
Oh my god.
Everyone knows Miku.
She transcends generations.
Are you doing, should we do one last chat?
Yeah.
We can do one last.
Yeah, we actually did two hours.
I'm so, so funny.
Oh, wow.
That went by fast.
Time passed by.
It does.
Yeah, I'm back to being Niki.
Same.
Niki.
I'm going to be forever.
Miku forever.
Kids don't have typing rights.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Their mom took their PC away.
They're not playing on their PC.
They're probably playing on their iPad or something, right?
Why are they saying only one more and why are they crying?
Wait, are they watching your stream?
Oh, yeah.
That's the post person, right?
What have you done?
Hello.
Guys.
I'm not streaming right now though.
Oh, they're listening.
Dude, they're watching the stream.
They're stream sniping, guys.
Oh, no, it's kidding.
What's the theme?
Live child.
Everyone here is a fan.
They're all our fans, guys.
Fat of you.
Everyone, all of us, all of us.
All the children, leave.
Don't watch the stream.
Wait, what is Casio big?
What the heck is Casio big?
So we all look the same then?
Oh, wow.
We all have to do one person.
Wait, look it up.
Look it up.
Casio.
No, it's like with person.
Yeah, and he's just wearing a hoodie.
I've seen this guy.
He's like a streamer.
He's the one.
He has like funny clips.
I've seen his clips before.
So what does he wear?
He just wears a big, gray hoodie.
Like he wears big hoodies and like he dresses like a man.
Normal guy.
He just dresses like a dude.
There's not much to go off of.
There's not even a male on there, is there?
Oh, I'm going to make him pretty with some layers.
All right.
Yeah, I'm going to do it later.
I'm not going to change my character
from being a hecking woman, though.
I can't be bothered.
I'm a man.
We're all just going to look the same.
Yeah, let's look the same.
Are you a kitten?
What's up?
Oh, my God.
Why is the teddy bear so expensive?
I know, right?
It's so cute.
It looks so expensive.
Let's see.
I'm going to put a dress, like a skirt on him.
We're all, we're literally all just going to look
like the same kind of girl.
He's just a big guy.
I can't wear the skirts.
No.
This is discrimination.
And you do guy hairs.
He's like a ginger too, right?
Yeah.
We do like a guy hairstyle.
We can't do guy hairstyles, though.
We can give ourselves shortish hair.
Yes.
Can you have beards in this game?
You can.
I gave myself a mustache.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, oh, no, no, no.
I kind of just look like PewDiePie.
There's only like six male hair styles.
What?
Yeah.
Damn.
Oh, this is all right.
Guy's got it rough in this game.
Yeah.
Every customization game.
It's not always Lamer.
None of these faces look like him.
None of these faces look like him, too.
This is ginger.
This is not.
Oh, God, oh, God.
This is, yeah, this is too fun.
They need to be more ginger.
More ginger.
Yeah, like that.
Do you do this one?
Oh, good take.
Here we go.
Oh, oh my.
Um, there's, there's really not.
There's not much to pick from.
No.
Maybe I'll go a little bit different.
I see pictures of him with a blue sweater.
So I'm going to not be like the other girls,
and I'm going to go with the blue sweater instead.
Wait, I did the blue hoodie, too.
I did the blue.
You did the blue.
What?
Damn.
We're all so basic.
What if, or what if we just go like, let's see.
I'm going to go like this.
He's just a dude.
He's just a guy.
He's just, he's just a dude that dresses like a guy.
I can't put on the teddy necklace.
What?
No, that's for a wait.
I'm going to do the shirt man.
This one.
He has a photo of him shirtless.
I'm just going to go with this.
Okay, let's put on like.
I'm gorgeous.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
And he was doing a beanie.
Where do I see a beanie?
That's like normal beanie.
I can't wear gloves.
What?
I go like this.
I saw a beanie earlier.
It's um.
Where the fluffy clothes are.
It has cat ears, but it's okay.
This is cat ears.
It's a cat ear beanie.
Where's the plain one?
There's a plain one on the left.
Right above the cat ear one.
Oh, it's like a, not a beanie.
Kind of like a, I should call it.
Oh, okay.
This beanie does look bad though.
I'm going to put a, I'm going to put a hat on instead maybe.
Yeah.
Does he wear a hat like that?
Not really.
He's either wearing nothing or like blue or red hoodie in the pictures I'm seeing.
Yeah.
I'm doing topless.
You guys are using the skin tone.
All right.
Oh, that's, that's my final attempt.
Wait, how do you make beard?
You have to choose the face with the beard.
The face of the beard.
Oh no.
No, I like my face.
Whatever here.
Oh yeah.
Forgot he has a.
Oh no.
I did something wrong.
Oh my God.
The cat is so cute.
Does he have a cat?
I don't know.
Someone.
But.
Laffy.
What do you know?
What?
Oh, what's wrong?
Great red makeup.
I wanted to try something new.
Reinventing style.
That's our mission, right?
Yeah, girl.
Looks so lost.
Oh my God.
Hello.
I'm going to go out and make a move.
Yeah.
I spiced.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Everyone's going to look the same.
Here, I'll do some poses.
Wow.
The lips.
What do you use for our escape or lip care?
There I go.
Weirdo.
Oh, I gave up.
You don't have to say ooh about this.
Cute.
It's cute.
I couldn't be bothered to change it to guy.
It's so much effort.
Well, it's just like putting on a shirt or something.
You just go to the guy and click on him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shirtless.
I'm liking it.
Oh, the pose.
The pose.
Slime star.
Let's go.
I like the hairstyle.
Oh my God.
Layers off.
I found a picture of a lady's shirt.
Ooh, fashionable.
Oh, I like the pants.
Call me fat and I'll shoot.
I put the stockings on last second.
Wait, I do remember a clip of him
where he was like, nice person to call me fat
gets banned or something like that.
Wait, actually?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Wait, this isn't getting censored.
What the heck?
Yeah, wait, how is that not getting censored?
But everything else was.
Yeah, it's true.
The jurors get censored.
It just doesn't make sense.
Justin Bieber gets censored.
Censorship in this game doesn't make sense.
They got their priorities.
Oh my God.
He's got no face.
OK.
No face.
Metaphor, four.
What?
What was that?
I did not like that.
I'm removing a star just for that.
What was that?
Yeah, who was that?
How do you do that?
I jump scare.
Is that a glitch?
Oh, wow.
Oh, wait, he has a cat?
OK.
The cat is really cute.
Extra stars for the cat.
Yeah.
There's four stars for the cat.
Four stars because of the cat.
Because of the cat.
Oh my God.
Oh, that looks really good.
Oh, the throat, you see that?
You're layered on layers.
Yeah.
You guys don't see the throat glitch?
The throat?
What?
No.
It's like glitching between black and
and it's like.
Oh, it doesn't have a dragon.
What is this?
Go away.
Who's doing this?
Yeah, how do you do that?
What the hell?
That is going on.
You got to go the slay one.
Yola, let's go.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
All right.
Alrighty.
Thank you.
Where's everybody?
Let's be together.
Oh, yeah.
Let's all get together.
All right.
Where are we?
Your face is on.
Hi.
Where should we?
In the white makey mound.
There you go.
All right.
Everyone.
Pose pose.
Number 12.
Oh, pose.
OK, OK, OK.
There we go.
Wait, wait.
I got a.
OK.
There we go.
Oh, beautiful.
Adorable.
Nice.
Who are these people?
Move.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I got my help.
I'm here.
Like, I'm hitching.
Look at you.
Oh, no.
Why is it got?
There you go.
Nice.
They're getting in my face.
I'm trying to take a screenshot.
Oh, me too.
They know what I'm going to do,
madam said.
Oh, they did a screenshot.
Brett.
Why are they all here?
Everybody's here.
It's everyone watching the stream.
It's everyone we're playing with
actually, like, our viewers.
Hi, guys.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, guys, for playing.
Thank you for playing.
Thank you.
Hope you guys enjoyed.
Welcome to Roblox.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for inviting Roblox.
Thank you for inviting me.
Yeah.
All right.
Bye-bye.
Have a good day, guys.
Bye.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm going to leave the game.
Leave.
And then let me go back to the chatting screen.
That was interesting.
That was my first time ever actually playing Roblox.
I'm kind of sad.
I bought a cute little avatar before we started
because I thought, like, I could use it, but I can't.
Here, let me show you what she looks like.
That's her.
Look how cute she is.
I couldn't use her at all.
Also, do not send me friend requests on Roblox.
I will not accept them.
Same thing with Discord.
I keep getting Discord friend requests.
I will not accept them.
But look how cute.
That's me.
Okay, I didn't make this.
I bought it for $7, but it's so cute.
She does have some stompers.
They are really big, but it's really cute.
I know I couldn't use her.
You mugged everyone in the room?
Not really.
But I did have fun.
I enjoyed myself.
I enjoyed playing Roblox.
Much more than I expected to, to be honest.
Much more than I put a lot more effort than I expected to put.
I tried really hard to make it look good.
It was a fun stream.
I'm glad you liked it.
No, you're cultivating your fan base with fashionists kids now.
No, no, don't.
I don't know who said go subscribe to Amy in the chat,
but don't do that.
Roblox is full of kids.
I, I, I don't, we don't, we don't, we don't, we don't, we don't
want to invite.
Oh, sorry.
I'm clicking on my keyboard back.
So we don't invite kids to this stream.
We don't invite kids.
Kids, kids are not allowed in the stream.
Okay.
Um, yeah.
You should have won that Justin round.
Justin looked bad.
Justin looked ugly.
I shouldn't have.
I should have picked someone else, but
um, I, I didn't know who to pick and I thought Justin would be easy.
Not even to teach about the dangers of airplanes.
No, for nothing.
Kids are not allowed here for anything.
Do you still have VC?
No, I don't know how to VC in Roblox, but I just wanted to,
I thought it would be funny to troll on the kids a little bit, but uh,
I don't even know how it's fine.
The kids discovering porn things.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We don't do that.
I don't even know what that word means.
What, what is that?
I've never done anything like that.
Don't accuse me of things I, I don't do.
Okay.
Just like a tanked up or baggy shirt and buzz cut for what?
For Justin Bieber.
I tried going for like his younger years.
That's more, um, that's more iconic.
You know, yeah.
Let's see.
Oops.
This is not the right tab.
She's going to raise the next generation of Cooners.
No, we're not raising anyone.
We're not raising no kids here.
Absolutely not.
Is he alive right now?
Is he dead?
Did he die?
Is he alive?
Here, hold on.
I am a bad, I thought I, hold on.
Oh, thank you for the $15.
Thank you.
Rui's not streaming.
Did she finish the stream?
Yeah, she finished the stream.
Um,
and Alaya.
Don't tell them, but I forgot to subscribe to them on YouTube.
I'm literally doing that right now.
Oh, they all ended the stream already.
Okay.
I will also-
Alaya, fuck Elia.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
Alaya, Alaya.
Amy would never do anything on Seiso on YouTube.
No, no, I wouldn't.
Anyways, Strani's still streaming right now.
She's playing Tavern Master.
So I'm going to read her.
Um, I'm going to just put the link in chat.
Oops, I'm going to put the link in chat.
I, okay, I am having a really bad tummy ache.
So I don't think I'll be, I don't think I'll be in chat.
I will be on the toilet.
I'm feeling it really hit right now.
And I'm wondering if it's from my coffee,
because I did drink coffee this morning.
Oh my God, it's really hitting me.
Um, um, yeah, okay.
I'll see you tomorrow, I think.
I think tomorrow.
Um, yes, thank you for coming.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Have a nice day.
This is so strange to stream so early in the day.
I never stream this early.
Um, also someone, I remember someone said like,
doesn't, Amy, Amy, Amy's on Twitter
while she's on the toilet, isn't she?
And you're right.
I am on Twitter while I'm on the toilet.
I'm on Twitter on the toilet a lot.
I'll probably be on Twitter on the toilet right now.
I, I do, I do be on the toilet.
I'll be tweeting and shitting.
How do I, I will set up the raid,
but I don't think it's going to work.
So I will do, I will also just give you the link.
There.
All right.
See you tomorrow, hopefully.
If I'm getting the date right, I think.
Yeah, tomorrow's a member stream though.
So if you're not a member, see you Saturday.
Have a good day.
Thank you for watching me play Roblox.
Um, yeah, see ya.
Bye-bye.
Love you.
Bye.